Pete Davidson removed his Kim Kardashian  inspired tattoo what are your thoughts  about tattoo removal being spontaneous  and putting a tattoo on you know early  what are your what is what does Tink  think I well you know I have some  personal experience I have I have a new  boyfriend and he got my initials on his  arm wait what and what was your response  um well I I mean I think initially I was  I know I'm really flattered it's it's  flattering it's exciting but it's early  I mean we're like we're like seven weeks  in so whoa yeah so it's a little bit  early but I I'm I'm so thankful to Pete  for reminding us that tattoo removal is  an option should we get to that point  not that I not that I'm putting that out  there but I you know it's it's an option  which is good